اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نستكمل تغطتنا للصراع
الجاري في السودان والذي اتم اسبوعه
الثاني ميدانيا تجددت الاشتباكات بين
الجيش بقياده البرهان والدعم السريع
بقياده دجلوفي عده نقاط سيما محيط القصر
الجمهوري بالخرطوم اتهامات متبادله بين
الطرفين بخرق الهدنه الخامسه على وقع
اشتباكات متقطعه داخل العاصمه وخارجها
الجيش وصل طلعاته الجويه بالمروحيات
والطائرات الحربيه على مواقع الدعم السريع
فيما ردت قوه الاخيره بمضادات الطيران
يحدث ذلك في الوقت الذي تتسابق فيه دول
العالم لاجلاء رعاياها وفي هذا السياق
اعلنت انقره تعرض طائره اجلاء تركيه
لاطلاق نار بمطار وادي سيدنا في الخرطوم
ولا اصابات الجيش السوداني تهم قوات الدعم
السريع باستهداف الطائره التركيه والاخيره
نفت
[موسيقى]
وصل عدد ضحايا بمعارك الجنينه عاصمه ولايه
غرب دارفور الى 74 قتيلا على الاقل خلال
يومين وفق نقابه اطباء السودان النقابه
اوضحت الرقم في بار لها ليومي الرابع
والعشرين والخامس والعشرين من ابريل ولم
يتم حصر العدد بعد لوفاه يومين الاربعاء
والخميس في خضم استمرار المعارك العنيفه
في الجنينه
وصل عدد الضحايا بمعارك الجنينه اذا كما
اشرنا عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور الى اربعه
وسبعين قتيلا على الاقل خلال يومين وفق
نقابه اطباء السودان النقابه اوضحت الرقم
في البيان لها في يومي الرابع والعشرين
والخامس والعشرين
في عموم السودان قالت اللجنه التمهيديه
لنقابه اطباء السودان الى عدد المدنيين
الذين قتلوا منذ بدء الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع ارتفع الى
387 قتيلا وذكرت اللجنه في بيان ان
الاشتباكات اسفرت عن اصابه
1928 مدنيا حتى الان واشار البيان الى
سقوط عشره من القتل المدنيين امس الخميس
بينما اصيب ثمانين اخرون بينهم حالات غير
مستقره
الجيش السوداني كان اعلن هدنه جديده
استجابه لمساعن سعوديه امريكيه واعرب
الجيش السوداني عن امله في التزام من
وصفهم بالمتمردين في اشاره لقوات الدعم
السريع بمتطلبات سريان الهدنه واوضح الجيش
السوداني ان تمديد الهدنه تم استجابه
لمسائل سعوديه امريكيه لتهيئه الظروف
لاجلاء المقيمين من مختلف الجنسيه
وانضم الينا من الخرطوم اسامه ابو بكر
المسؤول الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر السوداني
اهلا بكم بدايه من خلال متابعتكم لتطورات
الاحداث على الارض الى مدى تقدرون ان هناك
التزاما بالهدنه التي تم تمديده
والله حتى الان الهدنه ماشيه يمكن حسب ما
بنشوف في جسم الاعلام في اشتباكات هنا
وهناك
لكن نحن بنستفيد من اي هدنه حتى ولو كانت
محدوده وقصيره على اساس انه نحن نحاول
يعني نزيد من فعاليتنا ونستفيد من الهدنه
لكن طبعا نحن الهدنه عايزينها تكون اطول
من كده بشكل عام مش نحن في الهلال الاحمر
كل المؤسسات والمنظمات الانسانيه بتحاول
تكون انه الهجمه طويله اطول من كده وفيها
ضمانات اكثر الى اي مدى استفدتم حتى الان
من الهدن التي تم تطبيق
والله بتخلينا نتحرك شويه الهلال الاحمر
عندنا
التحيه الاوليه والاخلاق بتدينا شويه انه
نوصل من بين المستشفيات وكذا نحن نساعد
التوازن الطبيه في 18 مستشفى العاصمه ايضا
الهدنه هي الهدنه في الخرطوم انا ما اعرف
دلوقتي ناسنا في الولايات لانه شغالين في
في ولايات
من الطرفين يعني
بنحاول نحن نستفيد الهدنه احيانا الهدنه
بتاعه الخرطوم بتختلف من الهدنه بتاعه
المناطق ماذا يختلف بين هدنه الخرطوم
وباقي الولايات
لانه هي الهدنه في اغلب الاحياء ما بتكون
ساريه على مستوى السودان يعني هي طبعا
لانه التركز الاحداث الخرطوم
بتكون فيه اعتبارات تعني لدى اطراف النزاع
في الولايات التاليه يعني ممكن تكون في
جودان جزئيه يعني ممكن يعملوا مثلا في
مدينه من المدن معينه باتفاق الطرفين وكذا
على العموم هو في الولايات نحن شغالين
بسعوديه اكثر شويه تعتمد طبعا على حسب
الولايه وعلى حسب اتصالاتنا
سؤال انه هل يتم التعرض لكم من قبل قوات
الدعم السريع او الجيش هل رصدتم تعرض لكم
من قبلهم ام انه يتم السماح لالياتكم
واطقمكم بالتحرك بحريه
ما حصل لحد هسه ما عندنا حادثه انه
يتعارضوا لنا لسبب بسيط انه الطرفين الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني يعلمون بالضبط
الهلال الاحمر ما هو الهلال الاحمر
مستقله عن السلطات السياسيه ومستقله عن
الحكومه وتعمل عمل انساني بيستفيدوا منه
حتى الطرفين يعني احنا مثلا عندنا تجربه
اتعملت في مدينه
نيالا في ولايه جنوب دارفور كان في
ناس متوفيين زي السبعه قصص متوفيه تم
قتلهم في مناطق تابعه للطرف الى الاطلاق
فيتصلنا بالجهتين بدعم السريع
الجيش السوداني
تجهيز طاقم من المطوعين الهلال الاحمر
اخل هذه الجثث يعني هناك اتصالات بينكم
وبين الجيش وفي المقابل هل هناك اتصالات
خطوط اتصالات بينكم وبين قوات الدعم
السريع ايضا
طبعا نحن اتصالاتنا مع الطرفين لان احنا
نحنا جهاز جهه محايده بين الطرفين يعني هم
نحمي الضحايا ونقدم المساعده للضحايا ولو
ما واثق فينا الطرفين في حياتنا يعني ما
حنقدر نشتغل بكل الثلاثه عشان كده في
مدينه الجنينه عفوا في مدينه نياله تم
تطبيق هذه النسخه الحرفيا لسقط الطرفين
عندنا فريق بتاع اخلاء
الجسانين بيشتغل بالاسس العلميه وفقاطع
العالميه
اخذنا جسامين الطرف الى الطرف الاخر
هذه معلومه مهمه اذا قمتم من خلال التنسيق
بين الطرفين باخلاء جثامين وتبادل جثامين
المكونين وارسالهم لبعضهم البعض خصوصا في
المناطق التي تحدث فيها اشتباكات هل هناك
تقديرات لاعداد هذه الجثانين التي تم
نقلها
نحن عندنا نقلنا سبعه جسامين اول امبارح
اللي هي كانت تتبع
الاحاد احد الطرفين تم قتلهم في منطقه
سيطره الاخر يعني
وبالتالي نحن عشان ننقل الجسامير نجيب
للطرف الثاني اللي هو
المتحارب مع الطرف ده نسقنا مع القوات
المسلحه ونستخدم مع الدعم السريع والاثنين
قبلوا الوساطه بتاعتنا في الى اي مدى
تستفيدون من اتصالاتكم مع الجانبين ربما
لاخلاء باقي الجثث الموجوده في الخرطوم
كانت تقرر اشاره ونحن ندخل في الاسبوع
الثاني الى ان هناك الكثير من الجثث
موجوده في شوارع العاصمه هل ما زالت هذه
الجثث موجوده ام نجحتم في اخلائها
لا اول حاجه طبعا في الخرطوم الجثث عدد
كبير جدا واحد اثنين اتساع للرقعه
الجغرافيه بتاعت ولايه الخرطوم يعني نحن
لو عايزين نغطي ولايه الخرطوم كلها
بمحليات السبعه هي هي حاجه ضخمه جدا عدد
سكانها اصلا في الامتدادات الحضريه
والاقتدادات الثانيه ولايه الخرطوم فيها
ما يقارب 10 مليون نسمه العشره مليون نسمه
المواطنين طبعا
يشكلوا تقريبا اقل شويه من ربع سكان
السودان فالعمل في عمل صعب جدا يحتاج
لضمانات امنيه حتى الاطراف المتنازعه تضمن
انه تصل المعلومه لاصغر جندي في اي منطقه
معينه نحن بنحاول نلقى مساحات في ساعه
حريه بالتنسيق مع الطرفين واحيانا ما في
تصديق بين الطرفين لكن احنا بنراهن على
فهم الطرفين لطبيعه عمل الاحمر وبنقوم
بهذه الاعمال يعني حصل اخل
نعم نعم تقصد ابدا نشاطاتنا في مثل تحديات
التي تواجهكم في محاوله مساعده الناس
واخلاء الجرحى وايضا ربما بعض الجثث
التحديات التي تواجهنا بتتمثل في حاجتين
اول حاجه في عدم وجود ضمانات امنيه
على مستوى ولايه
لكن نحن بنحتاج ضمانات امنيه لانه بالنسبه
لنا المتطوعين الذنوب باخلاء هذه الجثث او
بقوه باعمالهم اهم عنصر الهلال الاحمر
خالص يعني اهم من الموظفين المطوع ناس
بيضحوا حياتهم وامكانياتهم الذاتيه شحيحه
عشان يتحركوا وبالتالي نحن ما بنرى امر
برواحل المتطوعين ما لم نتاكد تماما انه
في ضمانات امنيه من كلا الطرفين لذلك
المساله تخضع لاتصالات احيانا بتكون ثنائي
ما بتكون اتصالات على المستوى الملكي ماذا
عن النقطه الثانيه
النقطه الثانيه اللي هي بالنسبه لاخلاء
الجرحى وبالنسبه لاخلاء الجسانين يعني
يعني اخلاء الجرحى متطوعين مثلا في ولايه
الخرطوم عندنا 254 متطوع
متخصصين في الاسعافات الاوليه لو تحدد لنا
ابرز الاماكن التي تحدث فيها الاشتباكات
والتي يمكن اعتبارها من قبلكم خطره
عالي جدا جدا فهلال احمد والنقص اصلا حتى
في المستشفيات
والاجهزه
الطوارئ في المستشفيات
جدا جدا
بسبب بسيط جدا هل تتلقون اي دعم خارجي
نحن عاده بنتلقى دعم هذه كبيره جدا اول
حاجه الدعم ده بدينا من اللجنه الدوليه
لصليب الاحمر الذين الدوليه للقريب الاحمر
هي زي ما بيقولوا نحن زي الاشقاء يعني كل
واحد عنده دول اللجنه الدوليه للطبيب
الاحمر في حالات النزاعات المسلحه هي
الجهه الوحيده في العالم المفوضه بالتدخل
ومساعده ضحايا النزاع المسلح بما بكل
المقاييس
لدى الطرفين او جرحى او مصابين يلا اللجنه
الدوليه بتعتمد على الهلال الاحمر لانه
الهلال الاحمر هو عنده اكبر قاعده متطوعين
حسب الاحصائيات اللي اتعمل يمكن سبع سنين
عندنا في السودان 420 الف متطوع جيد انا
اشكرك على كل هذه المعلومات التي قدمتها
لنا اسامه ابو بكر المسؤول الاعلامي
الهلال الاحمر السوداني كنت معنا من
الخرطوم وانتقل الى مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي الذي ينضم الينا من جنوب الخرطوم
اهلا بك يا سالم كيف تبدو الاوضاع لديك
الان على الارض
نعم اخر التطورات على الارض ان هنالك
مدافع ثقيله وخفيفه في مناطق متفرقه من
العاصمه الخرطوم وتحديدا في ليس ببعيد من
مطار الخرطوم او في محيط مطار الخرطوم قبل
قليل لكنها كانت وتيره يعني في زمن وجيز
لم تكن متواصله لوقت طويل كما كان في
بدايه هذه الاشتباكات كذلك تجددت
الاشتباكات في مناطق اخرى من ام درمان
وكذلك مدينه بحري لكنها هي الاقل حده كذلك
في مدينه بحري هنالك الان ايضا حريقين
ضخمين في المنطقه الصناعيه في الخرطوم
يضاف اليهما كذلك ان الحركه اصبحت اصعب
منذ بدايه الاشتباكات اصبحت الطرق المتاحه
لمرور المواطنين محدوده كذلك وهي مليئه
كذلك بالارتكازات هذا كله يدفعنا للحديث
عن حركه النزوح ايضا اللافته للانتباه
لكثير من المواطنين الذين نجحوا من هذه
المناطق اما الى ولايه مجاوره او حتى خارج
السودان ذلك حركه النزوح بدات في ازدياد
مضطرد منذ بدا هذه الاشتباكات الكثير من
المواطنين خرجوا من منازلهم خاصه المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها قوات الدعم السريع خوفا
على حياتهم لان هذه المنطقه بكل تاكيد هي
مستهدفه من الجيش السوداني من قبل لانه
يستهدف قوات الدعم السريع وهي تتمرس في
هذه المناطق مما يجعل حياه المواطنين مع
الكثير نحن نشاهد في الصوره من خلفك هذه
الصوره المباشره
دخان في سماء الخرطوم لو تشرح لنا ماذا
يوجد خلفك وهذه المناطق هل شهدت اشتباكات
اليوم
من خلف تماما هذه الاعمده الدخان هي في
مدينه بحري وفي المنطقه الصناعيه الصناعيه
ذات الحريقين الذين تحدثت عنهما
الكاميرا لا ادري اذا كان هذا متاحا سالم
هل تستطيع
تحريك الكاميرا ممكن تماما بكل تاكيد هذه
المنطقه هي مدينه بحري التي اندلع فيها
الحريق في هذه المنطقه بالتحديد والان في
هذه اللحظات وفي هذه الاثناء نستمع الى
اصوات مدافع كذلك في الجهه الشرقيه كذلك
وهي جهه مطار الخرطوم هذه المنطقه منطقه
بحري اندلع في حريقين في السوق المركزي في
مدينه بحري او عفوا في المنطقه الصناعيه
في بحري اندلع هذين الحريقين ولم يعلم ما
هي الاسباب لهذين الحريقين حتى الان مررنا
بالقرب منهما وجدنا اعداد من المواطنين
وليس ببعيد منهما ارتكازات لقوات الدعم
السريع موجوده في تلك المنطقه هذه المناطق
تنتشر فيها قوات الدعم السريعه
هل تم قصف هذه المناطق بالطائرات ما
المعلومات لديكم حول هذا الامر خصوصا اننا
دخلنا في تمديد للهدنه هل هناك اي تحليق
للطائرات بعد اعلان الدخول في الهدنه
الثانيه
تحليق الطائرات كان صباح اليوم كانت
الطائرات قليلا في بدايه هذا اليوم كان
هناك تحليق لبعض الطائرات ثم بدا هذا
الامر في التلاشي حتى هذه اللحظه توقف
تحليق الطائرات في فوق السماء الخرطوم لكن
الجيش السوداني ظل يقول انه ملتزم بهذه
الهدنه وان الدعم السريع هو من يخترق هذه
الهدنه وهناك تبادل للاتهامات في هذا
الامر فيما يتعلق الالتزام بهذه الهدنه
على الارض لم نشهد الى هذه اللحظه هدنه
كامله بعدم اطلاق النار او الالتزام
الكامل بهذا المبدا مبدا عدم اطلاق النار
ولا يسمع المواطن ولا طلقه واحده منذ
بدايه هذه الاشتباكات وحتى الان اين تتركز
الشبكات خصوصا خلال الساعات الاخيره كان
هناك انباء بانه في محيط القصر الرئاسي
وايضا حول المطار وايضا مقر القياده بشكل
محدود الى اي مدى هذه الانباء دقيقه
نعم هذا صحيح لكن يضاف اليه الاشتباكات
التي هي موجوده في مدينه ام درمان في محيط
الاذاعه والتلفزيون سمعت ايضا اصوات
للذخيره والمدافع الثقيله والخفيفه كذلك
في الجهه الجنوبيه منهم درمان منطقه صالحه
ايضا تشهد كذلك اشتباكات وسماع لدويه
اطلاق النار وكذلك المدافع الثقيله
والخفيفه لكن
اذا كان بامكانك اذا كان بامكانك سالم ان
تبقى معنا بالاتصال بالصوت وان تخرج من
الكادر قليلا كي تتيح للمصور ان يعطينا
صوره
ابرز واشمل مشهد الخرطوم
نعم يمكن
يمكن يمكن ذلك بالنظر الى هذه المناطق
التي ذكرتها الان بالمجمل مدينه بحري هي
الاقل الان في الاشتباكات وفي تجدد
الاشتباكات خلال هذا اليوم مدينه بحري
ربما تشهد هدوءا نسبيا قليلا عكس ما يدور
في الخرطوم وكذلك في ام درمان طيب الان
فيما يتعلق بحركه النزوح ذكرت بان هناك
حركه نزوح تتزامن مع دخولنا الاسبوع
الثاني من هذه الاشتباكات الى اين تتركز
داخليا وايضا حجم وتقديرات اعداد من تركوا
الخرطوم بسبب هذه الاشتباكات
نعم بالنسبه لعمليه النزوح عمليه النزوح
في الغالب هي تتركز في اطراف الخرطوم
واندرمان وبحري في كل واحده منهما هنالك
منفذ يخرج الى واحده من الولايات لكن
بالمجمل هذه حركه النزوح مستمره الى
الولايات المجاوره لولايه الخرطوم اذا
تحدثنا عن ولايه الجزيره هنا شرقا اول
جنوب الشرقي وكذلك شمالا في منطقه الولايه
الشماليه ونهر النيل كذلك هذه الولايات
المتاخمه لولايه الخرطوم والقريبه منها
شهدت عمليات نزوح عاليه جدا وواضحه يضاف
اليها مساله النزوح الى دول مجاوره
كاثيوبيا مثلا او دوله مصر كذلك ايضا شهدت
حركه نزوح وحرص من المواطنين للخروج من
هذه المناطق التي تشكل خطرا على حياتهم
تحدثت عن وجود عدد كبير من ارتكازات في
الخرطوم هل رصدتم ربما او حددتم ايهما
يتمتع
بارتكازات اكثر سواء كان الجيش او الدعم
السريع
في المناطق التي تحدثنا عنها وهي المناطق
القريبه من الخرطوم وبحري هذه المناطق
القريبه من المناطق المركزيه اي من مركز
المدينه هذه المناطق تنتشر فيها بكثافه
قوات الدعم السريع وتقوم بعمليات تمشيط
ولديها ارتكازات عاليه الجيش السودانيه
تمركز في المناطق المحيطه بقياداته
والمناطق العسكريه التابعه للجيش السوداني
يتمركز فيها قوات الجيش السوداني وايضا
تحكم سيطرتها عليها وتحرص على وضع
ارتكازات في هذه المناطق يصعب فعلا الحديث
عن هذا الموضوع بدقه لكن المعرض في الشارع
يجد هذين الارتكازين وفي كل الاحوال كل
هذه الامور تنبي بان هنالك ذعرا وخوفا لدى
المواطن من هذه التحرك العسكري ووجود هذه
الاسلحه بكثافه في الشارع بهذه الطريقه
لان الارتكازات يحمل فيها الجنود العديد
من انواع الاسلحه مما يجعل المواطنين في
ذعر مستمر خاصه ان احيانا في الشارع
الواحد تجد اربعه او خمسه ارتكازات لهذه
القوات خاصه شكرا جزيلا سلام الهاشمي كنت
معنا من جنوب الخرطوم شكرا على كل هذه
المعلومات
رحب اعضاء الاليه الثلاثيه التي تضم
الاتحاد الافريقي والهيئه الحكوميه
الدوليه والامم المتحده اضافه الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والامارات وبريطانيا
وامريكا رحبوا باعلان الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع بتمديد وقف اطلاق
النار الحالي لمده اثنتين ساعه اضافيه
ودعوا الى تنفيذه بالكامل كما رحبت
الاطراف باستعداد طرفي النزاع في السودان
للدخول في حوار من اجل تحقيق وقف دائم
للاعمال الادائيه وضمان وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه دون عوائق
هذا وزاره قياده الدعم السريع السوداني
بيانا تضمن شكرا وتقديرا للاليه الثلاثيه
واللجنه الرباعيه وشكرت المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والولايات المتحده على جهودهما
المستمره في اجلاء المواطنين والمقيمين
منذ اندلاع الازمه في السودان واعلن بيان
الدعم السريع التزامه بمقترح الثلاثيه
والرباعيه بتمديد الهدنه الانسانيه لمده
72 ساعه ابتداء من الثانيه عشره ظهرا من
مساء الخميس 27 من ابريل الجاري
من جانبها رحبت القوى الامنيه الموقعة على
الاتفاق الاطار في السودان بالمبادره
السعوديه الامريكيه لتمديد الهدنه لمده 72
ساعه اشددت على ضروره الالتزام بها من اجل
الوصول لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار واضافت
انها تتابع عن كثب خطوات تنفيذ المبادره
الامريكيه السعوديه الراميه لوقف
المواجهات في السودان وتشدد على ايد وتشد
على ايدي قياده القوات المسلحه والدعم
السريع التي تعاطت بايجابيه مع هذه
المبادره
وضمن تفاعلها مع الوضع الانساني القائم في
السودان شكلت الحكومه الاثيوبيه لجنه
وطنيه لتسهيل عبور النازحين من الصراع
الدائري في السودان ودعت الحكومه
الاثيوبيه اطراف الصراع السوداني الى وقف
الاقتتال وانهاء معاناه المدنيين واكدت
دعمها للحلول السودانيه من دون تدخل اطراف
خارجيه
نتابع بقلق بالغ تطورات ما يجري في
السودان وقد قمنا بتشكيل لجنه وطنيه
تتراسها الخارجيه الاثيوبيه بالتعاون مع
جهات رسميه اخرى وقد قمنا بارسال فريق الى
الحدود مع السودان للقيام بتسهيل عبور
النازحين من الحرب الدائره هناك ونامل ان
يحل السلام في السودان في اقرب وقت
الصراع الدائر في السودان له تاثيرات
سلبيه على المفاوضات الثلاثيه في قضيه سد
النهضه ولا يمكن استئناف المفاوضات ما لم
يحل السلام في السودان ويكون هناك تركيز
تام من الجانب السوداني هذا الوضع يجعلنا
ننتظر حلول السلام في السودان
حصلت قناه العربيه على صور حصريه لعمليات
الاجلاء الجوي للرعايه الاجانب من السودان
والتي تجري تحت اشراف الجيش السوداني حيث
تظهر الصور اصطفاف طائرات عسكريه لاجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب وحتى السودانيه
[موسيقى]
كما تبعت كاميرا العربيه لحظات الاولى
لوصولي سفينه جلاله الملك جبيل الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بمدينه جده بالسعوديه
الان نشاهد بدا عمليات تجهيز السلم لبدء
انزال الرعايه
القادمين من ميناء بورت سودان وعددهم 52
شخص من 12 جنسيه نتحدث على دبلوماسيين
وعائلات واطفال وحتى كذلك كبار سن لانه
شاهد القوات العسكريه متواجده لاستقبال
الرعايه هنا في هذا في رصيف قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه بعد رحله استمرت عشره ساعات
كنا على متن هذه السفينه نرافقها من قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده الى ميناء بورت
السودان واستمرت عمليات الاجلاء في ظرف
ساعه واحده فقط عبر زوارق سريعه قامت بنقل
الرعايه من ميناء بورسودان الى
ظهر هذه السفينه السفينه جلاله الملك
الجبيل التابعه للقوات البحريه السعوديه
ومن ثم انطلقت مباشره من المياه الاقليميه
السودانيه الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده في رحله استغلقت كذلك عشره ساعات
فيما يتعلق بالتجهيزات الخاصه بالرعايه
هنا قامت القوات البحريه السعوديه بتجهيز
غرف نومتكانات لهؤلاء الرعايه وكذلك توفير
كافه المواد التموينيه والاعاشيه وكذلك تم
الكشف والتاكد من صحه وسلامه كافه الرعايه
من خلال وجود عياده طبيه هي مجهزه للتعامل
مع الحوادث والاصابات وكذلك اجراء
العمليات الخفيفه من خلال اطباء عسكريين
السعوديين متواجدون في هذه العياده
للتعامل مع اي حاله كذلك تم فتح كافه
المواقع المخصصه للاعاشه لهؤلاء الرعايه
حتى يستطيعوا التزود من الطعام والمشروبات
شابه ذلك طوال مده الرحله كذلك التعامل
بشكل انساني كبير جدا وواضح خلال طوال هذه
الرحله من خلال التعامل مع الرعايه وعند
اقترابنا من قاعده الملك الفيصل البح لو
دخلنا المياه الاقليميه السعوديه التقينا
بعدد كبير من الرعايه نتحدث على يعني
شرحوا وعبر لنا عن امتنانهم وتقديرهم
الحكومه السعوديه بعد انت قامت باجلائهم
من ميناء بورت سودان بعد ان كانوا في
الخرطوم وقاموا بالسفر برا الى ميناء
بورسودان في مده او في مسافه تصلي 850
كيلو متر يعني وثقوا هذه اللحظات عند
اقترابهم من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده وثقوا عبرها هواتفهم هذه اللقطات
واختلفت المشاعر بعد ان كان هنالك مشاعر
خوف وعدم استقرار اختلفت كليا بعد وصولهم
الى بر الامان هنا على ارض على ارض
السعوديه وتحديدا فعلى رصيف قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه بجده
تابعنا ايضا لحظات الاولى لوصول سفينه
جلاله الملك مكه الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بمدينه جده في السعوديه وعلى
متنها 195 شخصا من 18 جنسيه مختلفه
الان سفينه جلاله الملك مكه وهذا تاكيدا
على عمليات استمرار عمليات استمرار
الاجلاء الخاصه بالرعايه من ميناء بورت
سودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه عبر
السفن البحريه الخاصه بالقوات السعوديه
البحريه نتحدث على متن سفينه جلاله الملك
مكه التي وصلت الان
198 الشخص من نتحدث من 18
جنسيه جميعهم من المواطنين الاجانب وصلوا
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بعد رحله
استمرت قرابه العشره ساعات من بورت سودان
وتحديدا من ميناء بورت السودان
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه الان بدا
عمليات الالزام من خلال تركيب السلم الخاص
بالرصيف البحري الخاص ملك فيصل البحريه
دقائق معدوده وسوف يقومون بعمليات الانزال
بدءا من النساء وك بار السن ودول احتياجات
الخاصه وبعد ذلك بقيه الركاب
[موسيقى]
وتنضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو مديره مكتب
العربيه في السودان لينا يعقوب اهلا بك
لينا اذا لينا كيف يمكن توصيف ما يحدث في
الخرطوم
هي عمليات نزوح منظمه نزوح جماعي فرار
مضطرب ولماذا يفر الناس من الخرطوم
اهلا بك ابراهيم مساء الخير عليكم وعلى
جميع المشاهدين لا نستطيع ان نقول انه
الان نزوح جماعي او ان هناك قرار هناك بعض
الاسر المتضرره نحن نعلم ان التعداد
السكاني للسودان اكثر من 40 مليون نسمه
هناك الاف نحن لا نتحدث عن مئات الالاف
الان هناك الالاف الذين تضرروا جراء هذا
القصف او انا لديهم اسر وابناء في الخارج
قرروا الذهاب اما عبر القاهره او عبر اديس
ابابا للخروج الى دول اخرى اي ان هذه
الدول حتى هي معبر لهؤلاء السودانيين بعض
السودانيين ايضا الذين يحملون الجوازات
سفر اجنبيه ايضا قرروا الذهاب عبر
بورسودان والاجلاء هناك باعتبارهم ايضا من
الرعايه الاجانب ولكن هذه الاعداد محدوده
مقارنه باعداد السودانيين الباقيين حتى
اللحظه في العاصمه الخرطوم لكن انت
تتحدثين هنا وتشيرين الى اولئك الذين
قرروا مغادره السودان لكن فيما يتعلق
بالنزوح الداخلي الاعداد اكبر بكثير وهذا
ربما ما تبعناه
النهب والسرقه لكثير من المحال التجاريه
وكذلك داخل الاسواق كل هذا الامر ياتي
بحسب شهود عيان كما ظلمنا نقول في اوقات
كثيره بان قوات ترتديز يستعمل السريع تدخل
الى هذه البيوت وهناك الان قلق لانه لا
توجد سيطره حتى اللحظه للجيش السوداني على
كل مناطق الخرطوم ما زالت هناك عربات تتبع
للدعم السريع وقوات تتبع للدعم السريع
دخلت في بعض الاحياء السكنيه هذا الامر
يقلق كثير من السودانيين فاختاروا قرار
اما الذهاب الى اسر بعيده او الى مناطق
بعيده في ام درمان وبحري او انهم قرروا
الذهاب الى احدى ما يحدث في باقي ولايات
السودان وانضم الينا من دارفور الصحفي
صالح ابو علامه صالح بدايه هل كل ولايه
تشتهد اشتباكات اما الاشتباكات تقتصر فقط
على ولايه الجنينه
وهي اشتباكات بين الدعم السريع والجيش في
البدايه ولكن بعد ذلك تحولت الى اشتباكات
بين السكان في ولايه غربي دارفور مدينه
كما يعني تابعتم هذه الاشتباكات خلفت
العديد من القتلى والجرحى وحتى الان لا
توجد احصائيات
لكن دعني الان انقلك الى صوره اخرى انا
هنا في الميناء البري لمدينه الضعين عاصمه
ولايه شرق دارفور يمكن ان نرى صوره بهذه
الزاويه اليوم وجدنا في الميناء البري على
الكبير من الذين سروا من القتال في
اكتوبر جاءوا الى مدينه بعين على ظهر
كبيره والصغيره شرارا مما يحدث في
الخرطوم يعني ما يغريب الثلاثه الف مواطن
حضروا الى هذا المكان وما زالت الاعداد
متواليه قادمه من ولايه الخرطوم يعني
القادمين من الخرطوم يقولون بان الرحله
يستغرقت ما يقارب
اذا كما تحدثنا لينا الان يتحدث سنعود
ربما
لمراسلنا لنطلع على الاوضاع يتحدث بان
هناك ايضا حافلات تتجه الى دارفور من
ولايه الخرطوم رغم كل ما يحدث ايضا في
دارفور وبالتالي هذه حركه نزوح يمكن
تفسيرها بعوده العائلات الى مدنها الاصليه
ام ماذا
لا لا يمكن هذه الان حركه عشوائيه او هي
وهو فرار من مكان فيه قصف او فيه نقص كبير
جدا لاساسيات الحياه
الوضع في الخرطوم غير امن ولكن حينما
يتضرر الانسان في موقع معين يظن انه قد
يجد الامان في الخرطوم قد تحدث هذا هذه
الحركه العكسيه وهذا يوحيني الى سؤال اي
المناطق امنه الان في السودان كثير من
المناطق امنه تحديدا داخل الولايات
السودانيه يعني مثلا نحن نتحدث عن ولايه
الجزيره ولايه نهر النيل ولايات الشرق
القضارف كسلا بورسودان كذلك هناك مناطق لم
تشهد الولايات لم تشهد اي اشتباكات مثل
سنار جنوب كردفان شمال كردفان النيل
الازرق غيرها من هذه المدن غيرها من هذه
الولايه عفوا بالتالي هناك مدن كثيره امنه
لان الاشتباكات تتركز في العاصمه الخرطوم
او انها في احدى ولايات دارفور الجيش
السوداني كان يتحدث بان قوات من الدعم
السريع سلمت نفسها للجيش السوداني في بعض
المواقع العسكريه في الولايات السودانيه
لذلك لم يحدث اشتباك فضلا عنا الوجود وجود
الدعم السريع هو متمركز في دارفور وكذلك
في الخرطوم او تحديدا كانت في اطراف
الخرطوم في بعض المعسكرات لذلك نسبه لوجود
الاقل للدعم السريع في بعض الولايات
السودانيه هذا الامر يعني اسهم بصوره
مباشره ان تكون هذه الولايات امنه ومستقره
طيب الان فيما يتعلق بحركه النزوح هذه هل
هناك مسارات امنه يلجا لها الناس ام انهم
يغامرون بالخروج دون تنسيق مع اي طرف
في البدء كان المسار المؤدي من الخرطوم
مثلا الى ولايه البحر الاحمر وتحديدا الى
بورسودان كان غير امن ولكن بعد ذلك اصبح
الطريق بحسب المسافرين انه امن صحيح
يتعرضون فيه لكثير من التفتيش بعض عربات
الدعم السريع ايضا توقف المسافرين ويكون
هناك تفتيش بحسب
بعض المواطنين الذين تحدثنا اليهم ولكنه
حتى اللحظه على الاقل بدا من باستثناء
حالات السرقه حدثت وبعض الجرائم الصغيره
ولكن لم يحدث ان قصف مثلا باس يقل
المسافرين الى الى ولايه الجزيره او الى
ولايه نهر النيل حتى اللحظه اي انه لا
يوجد الان حتى اللحظه قصف متعمد للمدنيين
في هذا الطريق طيب فيما يتعلق بالاوضاع
الانسانيه في العاصمه الخرطوم تحدثنا عن
غياب للامن وخشيه من المواطنين لكن ماذا
عن الوضع الانساني موضوع الخدمات الى الان
ما زال مقلقا حتى الان كل التقارير تشير
الى
عدم وجود مياه صالح للشرب بالنسبه
للكهرباء هي شبه مقطوعه عن الكثير من
المناطق والاتصالات نواجه ايضا صعوبه في
ربط الاتصالات مع مراسلينا هناك لو تعطينا
نظره شامله على ابرز ما يتعلق بالوضع
الانساني والخدمات خصوصا في العاصمه صحيح
كثير من الهواتف وكثير من الخطوط الاتصال
الان يعني هي اما انها تعمل بصعوبه وانها
لا تعمل نحن نتحدث عن امداد الان للكهرباء
في بعض المناطق هناك عمال من هيئه
الكهرباء وكذلك هيئه المياه يعملون بصوره
شبه يوميه لاجراء اصلاحات لازمه في هذه
المناطق في اوقات كثيره تنجح وفي اوقات لا
تنجح هناك استمرار لهذه الخدمه في بعض
المناطق ولكن هناك ايضا مناطق ابراهيم
يعني لاحظنا تضررها بصوره كبيره تحديدا في
بحري نتحدث عن بحري يعني سكان الخرطوم
تاتي الكهرباء وتنقطع اما في بحري هناك
كثير من المناطق التي اضطر اهلها لترك هذه
المنازل لانقطاع الكهرباء والمياه يعني
بامكانهم ان يستحملوا ويصبروا ليومين
ثلاثه
ويحاولون ان يدبروا نفسهم ولكن حينما يطول
الزمن فلا بد ان يلجاوا الى خيار اخر
واعتقد ان هذا هو ما لجاوا اليه اما
بالخروج من بحري ومن بينهم حتى يعني من
يعملون في مكتب العربيه بعض الصحفيين بعض
من نعرفهم دعينا نتحدث مع اعاده الصحفيين
الذين يعملون الان من اندرمان عمار ابو
شيبه لو طلعنا على تطورات الاوضاع في ام
درمان اهلا بك عمار هل حدثت اي اشتباكات
بارزه في ام درمان بعد دخول التمديد
الثاني لهذه الهدنه
نعم يعني كانت هنالك عديد من الاشتباكات
منذ صباح اليوم وحتى قبل لحظات كانت هنالك
اشتباكات في منطقه الغربي
حسب المصادر التي تحدثنا اليها قبل قليل
هذه المصادر لان ذلك عدد من الجيوب لقوات
الدعم السريع في منطقه تحاول التواغل في
كل مره ولكن عدد من القوات الموجوده قوات
الجيش السوداني
تحاول التصدي في كل فتره وفتره بمنطقه
قبل ساعات من الان كانت هنالك اشتباكات
وكانت هنالك طلعات للطيران الحربي على
منطقه كافوري ومنطقه شرق
النيل يعني عدد من الاهالي هنالك تحدثوا
الينا وعدد الفيديوهات رسبت في هذه
المنطقه لتصاعد اعمده الدخان في عدد من
المناطق السكانيه وعدد من
المصانع التي تقع في المنطقه الصناعيه
بمدينه بحرين
كان حديث قبل قليل يعني فيما يخص منطقه
جنوب الخرطوم ومنطقه جبل الاولياء التي
تتحصل فيها قوات الدعم السريع يعني اصدرت
بيان قوات الدعم السريع بانها الصبح اليوم
شمت عليها الطائرات الحربيه غارات وهذا ما
ادى لخرق الهدنه وبالجانب الاخر رد الجيش
على ان قوه الدعم السريع هي من خرقت البنى
بالاعتداء على عدد من قواتها بالمنطقه
يبدو الان ان
صمود هذه الهدنه صعبا جدا في هذه اللحظات
رغم ان هذه الهدنه سمحت لي عدد كبير من
العالقين في منطقه وسط الخرطوم وحتى في
مدينه بحري لالتقاط عدد من الانفاس
والخروج من منطقه ذات اشتباك عالي وسمحت
ايضا لعدد من الحالات الانسانيه التي
تابعناها ولصقناها ان تذهب الى حاله اكثر
املا واكثر اتميدا حياه الناس في ام درمان
هل تشبه حياتهم في الخرطوم وبحري ام هناك
اختلاف
من خلال جوله ميدانيه الحياه هنا تبدو
طبيعيه بشكل واضح وكبير عدد من الاحياء
الان يعني يسالون السلامه لاهاليهم في
منطقه الخرطوم ومنطقه بحري ولكن هنا
الحياه تبدو طبيعيه عدد خطوط المواصلات
للعمل
المخابز يعني تشهد فيها نوعا ما اكتظاظه
وازدحام بحسب ان المواد التموينيه يعني
فيها نقص نوعا ما لان لان منطقه اندرمان
ايضا تعتمد على مناطق اخرى في الخرطوم على
يعني كثير جدا من التشوين والمواد
الغذائيه والمواد التي تعتمد عليها حياه
الناس بشكل واضح ولكن الحياه بدات طبيعيه
الخطوط المواصلات تعمل شبكه الاتصالات
تعمل نوعا ما بشكل جيد الخطوط الكهرباء
ليست هناك قطوعات تذكر عدد من المستشفيات
في هذه المنطقه
وبشكل كبير خاصه التي تقدم يعني خدمات
كبيره جدا كيف يمكن فهم هذا الامر باعتبار
انه ام درمان تشهد تواجد كبير لقوات الدعم
السريع
يعني لاحظناه في هذه المنطقه ان الجيش
يبسط السيطره بشكل
واضح على المداخل الاساسيه للمدينه وهذا
من خلال يعني شواهد تدل على ذلك مثلا
منطقه وادي سيدنا العسكري التي يجري فيها
او يجري فيها اجلال عدد من الرعايه
الاجانب هي منطقه يبسط الجيش سيطرتها
عليها مناطق مثل الاذاعه والتلفزيون
ومحيط هذه المنطقه من احياء الملازمين
وبيت المال هذه تشهد تحصيلات لقوات الدعم
السريع ايضا هنالك عدد من المناطق مثلا
منطقه
البشير ومنطقه جزء من منطقه المهندسين
تتواجد فيها قوات الدعم السريعه مدينه ام
درمان مدينه كبيره تمتد الى مساحات كبيره
حتى حدود
الولايه الغربيه ووصف السودان لذلك يستطيع
الجيش في هذه المدينه ان يبسط السيطره
واستطاعت يعني عديد من المساهمات القوات
المسلحه بهذه المنطقه ان تعيد اليها الامن
والامان وان تعيد تشغيل هذه المرافق
الحيويه حتى ان هنالك مناطق في هذه
المنطقه
مثل منطقه هذه المنطقه المعروفه قد خرجت
في مسيرات
دائما هو وفقت الكاميرات كاميرات
المواطنين تلك اللحظه هذا يبدو واضحا ولكن
هنالك مناطق ما زالت تتواجد فيها قوات
الدعم السريع
وتنشط في هذه المنطقه منطقه الاذاعه
والتلفزيون ومحيط هذه المنطقه ومعروفه ان
اصلا قوات الدعم السريع كانت تتواجد في
هذه المنطقه برفقه الجيش السوداني حين
تامين هذه المنطقه منذ
كانت تتواجد ولكن بحسب المعلومات ان قوات
الدعم كانت لها الاكثريه
بحكمه التركيبه والتوزيع العسكريه في هذه
المنطقه التركيبه التامينيه ربما هذه
المنطقه تتواجد فيها قوات الدعم السريعه
ولكن بقيه مناطق مدينه ام درمان تشهد
امانا كبيرا وحركه يعني من خلال تقديركم
ومشاهدات الناس في داخل ام درمان يعني
وحتى حدودها اي المكونين لديه تواجد عسكري
اكبر
قوات الجيش هي التي تنتشر بشكل اكبر وواضح
في هذه المنطقه وتتحدث المصادر العسكريه
لنا يعني بان قوات الدعم السريع في تلك
المناطق التي تتواجد فيها يتتحسن وهذه
بهذه الاماكن وهذه اماكن ذات كثافه سكانيه
عاليه هذه المنطقه تعربانه القديم
وتجاورها عدد من الاسواق المهمه جدا ربما
الجيش ما زال يعمل بسياسه الصبر والنفس
الطويل في هذه المنطقه
تلك المناطق باقل هذا ما يرد الينا من عدد
من المصادر وهذا ربما يعني طبعه الخطه
العسكريه الان على ارض الواقع طيب دعنا
نشاهد هذه الصور التي نبثها حصريا لقناه
العربيه هي صور للسوق المركزي في مدينه
بحري تشاهدين معنا لينا هذه الصور اذا هذا
هو السوق المركزي في مدينه بحري انا اشكرك
عمر ابو شيبه على وجودك معنا من ام درمان
ونتابع هذه الصور ثم نعلق عليها بعد قليل
لينا
لينا كثيرا ما تعرضوا السوق المركزي لقصف
لماذا من وجهه نظركم تم قصف هذا السوق وهو
يعني ليس موقعا عسكريا ومن الجهه التي
يمكن ان تستفيد من تدميره بهذا الشكل
اولا نحن
كالصحفيين وكمواطنين في اوقات كثيره لا
نعرف من الجهه التي قصفت ولكن انا لا
اعتقد انه يعني هو
قصف اكثر من انه نهب واحراق للسوق
يعني هذه الاماكن كانت تضج في الحياه قبل
بدء هذه الحرب الان كثير من هذه الشوارع
نشاهد انها اصبحت رماد بعد ادراما الحريق
فيها كل الفيديوهات التي نظرنا اليها في
وقت سابق ابراهيم كانت سرقه نهب صحيح اننا
نعلم ان هذا الامر دخيل على المجتمع
السوداني ولكن هناك محاوله ايضا لخلق
الفوضى اصحاب هذه المحل وانا القن على
لسانهم هم من يقولون بان هذه القوات هي
التي تدخل وفي الحقيقه هو الاتهام الذي
وجه للدعم السريع وكان قائد الدعم السريع
يحاول نفيه في اكثر من مره بان قواته لم
تدخل او لم تسرق او لم تنهب او لم ترتكب
بعض الجرائم في وسط الاحياء وكذلك في
السوق هناك كاميرات مراقبه مثبته في بعض
المحال بامكانها التقاط منهم الجهات التي
دخلت الى هذه الاسواق الى المحاله
التجاريه
حتى محلات الذهب لم تسلم من النهب
في بعض الاحيان نحن نلجا الى المنطق او
الى المعلومات ان كانت منطقه وسط الخرطوم
كان يسيطر عليها الدعم السريع تحديدا قرب
القصر الجمهوري في منطقه وسط الخرطوم قرب
ابراج النيلين في منطقه نمره اثنين مناطق
السكنيه هذه مناطق شهيده حالات
مباشره الى مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي
ينضم الينا من هناك سلطان السلمي من جده
سلطان
نحن نتابع معك مزيدا من الجاليات الغربيه
التي
تغادر جده لو توضح لنا جنسيه هذه الجاليات
والاعداد التي تستعد لمغادره السعوديه
للعوده الى اوطانها
بالفعل بدات الحكومه الصينيه بتنسيق مع
السلطات السعوديه ووزاره الخارجيه
السعوديه ببدا اجلاء الرعايه الصينيين الى
العاصمه الصينيه بكين بعدما تم اجلائهم من
ميناء بورتسودان عبر السفن البحريه الخاصه
بالقوات البحريه السعوديه الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه بجده منذ ايام الان نشاهد
379 شخص من الرعايه الصينيين يستعدون او
قبل قبل ان يستعدون يتم انهاء كافه
الاجراءات الخاصه بهم من قبل المديريه
العامه للجوازات وكافه القطاعات الحكوميه
العامله هنا في مطار الملكه عبد العزيز
الدولي بجده استعدادا لمغادره هؤلاء
الرعايه الصينيين الذين يبلغ عددهم 379
شخص كاول دفعه من الرعايه الصينيين
يغادرون الى العاصمه الصينيه بكين سوف
تغادر الطائره بعد ساعه ونصف من الان بعد
انهاء كافه الاجراءات الخاصه بهؤلاء
الرعايه الصينيين نتحدث او كده وكما اكدنا
عدد من المسؤولين في السفاره الصينيه ان
كافه الرعايه الصينيه الذين تم اجلائهم من
ميناء بورت سودان عبر السفن البحريه
السعوديه الى قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه
وصلوا جميعهم الى جده والان يتم اجلائهم
بالكامل كافه الرعايه الذين تواجدوا في
جده خلال اليومين الماضيه بعد عمليه
الاجلاء سوف يغادرون بعد الساعه ونصف من
الان عبر طائره بوينج تربل 7 تابع للخطوط
الصينيه
وسوف يغادرون جميعهم الى الصين في رحله
سوف تستغرق 10 ساعات من مطار الملك عبد
العزيز الدولي بجده الى مطار العاصمه
الصينيه بكين ايضا فيما يتعلق بالرعايه
يعني
يتم توزيع الورود على هؤلاء الرعايه الذين
يستعدون المغادره من قبل ضباط ورجال الامن
المطار الى اي مدى كان هناك ربما ارتياح
لدى الجاليه الصينيه وايضا باقي الجاليات
التي تم اجلائها من بورت سودان ووصلت الى
جده وكيف كانت اقامتها يعني حتى الابتسامه
تبدو على محايا هؤلاء الاشخاص من خلال
الصوره وهم يرفعون العلم الصيني وساعدونا
على ما يبدو بالعوده امنين الى بلدانهم
نعم بالفعل الصوتات السعوديه والقوات
البحريه السعوديه استقبلت هؤلاء الرعايه
عندما عندما تم اجلائهم عبر القوات
السعوديه من ميناء بورتسودان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده تم استقبالهم
بالحلوى والورود واليوم يودعونهم كذلك
بالحلوى والورود وحزمه من الاجراءات
الاستثنائيه للتسهيل على هؤلاء الرعايه
الصينيين ايضا فيما يتعلق بالخدمات
المقدمه لكافه الرعايه الصينيين وغير
الصينيين يتحدثون السعوديه اجلت
2991 شخص من 80 جنسيه اجنبيه منذ بدء
عمليات الاجلاء من ميناء بورت السودان الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه طوال الايام
الماضيه يتم استقبالهم وانهاء كافه
اجراءات الدخول للسعوديه في ظرف الساعه
واحده ومن ثم يتاكد من ثم يتم التاكد من
حالاتهم الصحيه وبعد ذلك يتم نقلهم الى
مقرات السكن الخاصه بهم في مدينه
السعوديه اربعه فنادق رئيسيه وضخمه حتى
يستطيعون الاقامه هؤلاء الرعايه لمده لمده
يومين ومن ثم يستعدون للذهاب الى بلدانهم
بعد التنسيق مع حكوماتهم والسلطات
السعوديه الان نشاهد هؤلاء الرعايه
الصينيين يغادرون الى الى بلدهم العاصمه
الصينيه بكين وعددهم 379 شخص يتم توديعهم
بالورود والحلو بعدين تم استقبالهم كذلك
بالورود والحلوه هنالك خدمات او مواقف
انسانيه كبيره وعلى يعني فقط هذه السيده
الصينيه
نعم تفضل نعم
تلتقط اخر الصور تلتقط صوره تذكاريه مع
احد الضباط بالمديريه العامه للجوازات
كذكرى قبل مغادرتها الى بلدها والتحديدا
العاصمه الصينيه
امتنان وتقدير كبير من قبل كافه الرعايه
الذين تم اجلائهم من بورت سودان الى مدينه
جده نتحدث عن قاعه الملك فيصل البحريه او
حتى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه وكذلك
حتى ايضا ميناء جده الاسلامي مشاعر وتقدير
كبير وامتنان للسلطات السعوديه بكافه
قطاعاتها والادارات التي عملت على هذا
الملف الخاص بالاجلاع من سهوله وتسهيلات
وتذليل كافه الصعوبات لهؤلاء الرعايه
والتعامل معهم بشكل بشكل انساني في المقام
الاول ومن ثم تسهيل كافه الاجراءات لهم
وعمل اجراءات استثنائيه حتى يستطيعون
الوصول الى بلدانهم بكل يسر وسهوله بعد ان
وصلوا الى بر الامان الى مدينه جده بعد
معاناه وفوضى عاشوا تفاصيلها بعد
الاشتباكات في ظل الاشتباكات المسلحه بين
قوات الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني خلال
الايام الماضيه سلطان السوره تتحدث مغادره
وكان هناك ربما مشاعر حقيقيه وامتنان
حقيقي من هؤلاء ولافت ما نشاهده حتى
توديعهم باللغه الصينيه وتم والتعامل نعلم
ان مديريه العامه
في المطار للتعامل مع من لا
يتحدثون
حتى كذلك المجندات السعوديه الذين يعملون
على انهاء الاجراءات هنا في كاونترات مطار
الملك عبد العزيز الدولي بجده يتحدثون
لغات مختلفه
ويتعاملون مع كافه الحالات الانسانيه
ويعملون على التقديم كافه التسهيلات
المتعلقه باجراءات السفر التي عملت عليها
مسبقا المديريه العامه للجوازات كتنفيذ
لخطه طوارئ خاصه لمثل هذه الحالات ايضا
نؤكد من المتوقع غدا صباحا مغادره كذلك
رحله على متنها قرابه 342 من الجاليه
الهنديه بعد ان تم اجلاهم خلال اليومين
الماضيه وقاموا بالاستراحه في جده لمده
يومين من المتوقع غدا صباحا تغادر طائره
هنديه من مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي
بجده الى الهند وعلامتها قرابه 342 شخص
ايضا من المتوقع بعد ان تمت عدد كبير من
عمليات الاجلاء خلال الايام الماضيه من
متوقع ان تزداد رحلات المغادره الجويه الى
بلدان مختلفه بعد ان الحكومه السعوديه
2991 شخص من 80 جنسيه مختلفه وصلوا الى
مدينه
كل هذه العمليه وبهم وانهاء كافه اجراءات
الدخول واستعدادا لمغادره
المغادره الى بلدانهم شكرا جزيلا لك سلطان
سلمى كنت معنا من مطار الملك عبد العزيز
الدولي وتابعنا معك عمليه اجلال الجاليه
الصينيه الى الصين انا اشكرك وايضا
الشكر موصول لك لينا على وجودك معنا خلال
هذه النشره شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الان الى موجز لابرز الاخبار الدوليه افاد
مسؤولون اوكرانيون بان روسيا اطلقت اكثر
من عشرين صاروخ كروز وطائرتين بدون طيار
على العاصمه كياب واجزاء اخرى من اوكرانيا
حيث اسفل الهجوم عن مقتل خمسه اشخاص على
الاقل وضرب مبنى سكني في وسط اوكرانيا
قال وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه
اصبحت جاهزه لشن هجوم مضاد على القوات
الروسيه وانها شارفت على نهايتها واضاف
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني بان هناك عوامل
تهيئ هذه الاستعدادات العسكريه للهجوم
المضاد منها عوامل الطقس وحيثيه القرار من
قبل القاده للبدء بالشروع بالعمليه
العسكريه المضاده
اعتبرها مجلس اوروبا في قرار اعتمدته
جمعيته البرلمانيه ان نقل روسيا اطفال
اوكرانيين بالقوه الى اراضيها يرقى الى
مستوى اباده جماعيه وضع المجلس الى اعاده
الاطفال بامان الى اوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان
هذه العمليات مخطط لها بوضوح وتنظم بشكل
منهجيك سياسه الدوله بهدف القضاء على اي
رابط مع هويه الاوكرانيه
اتهم وزير الدفاع روسيس الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها باستفزاز بعض الدول في مقدمتها
روسيا والصين لجرها الى مواجهه عسكريه مع
دول معارضه واضاف شويغو بان الهدف الحقيقي
من هذه السياسه التي تتبعها واشنطن هو
الحاق هزيمه استراتيجيه بروسيا وتشكيل
تهديد للصين للحفاظ على مكانتها
الاحتكاريه في العالم
قال خفر السواحل الفلبينيين هو دخل في
مواجهه خطيره مع سفن صينيه قامت بمناورات
في بحر الصين الجنوبي حيث اشار الى ان
سفينه صينيه اخرى لمناورات اجرت مناورات
خطيره على بعد 45 مترا تقريبا من سفينه
فلبينيه او سفينتين اخرىين نفذتا تكتيك
تكتيكات عدائيه شكلت تهديدا على سلامه
السفينه الفلبينيه وطاقمها من جانبها
الصين اتهمت الفلبين وقالت بانها قامت
بعمل استفزازي متعمد وحاولت تسبب في حادث
في بحر الصين الجنوبي
هذه الساعه انتهت الان نستكمل تغطتنا على
راس الساعه تفضلوا بالبقاء معنا في قناه
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات